do you do it proper tradition like this
don't do it don't do it oh god doctor do
it do it do it
like that
i got you
oh
oh god
[Music]
hello this is aaron taylor johnson and
i'm brian tyree henry and this is snack
wars on lab bible yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
this could be from today or from 30
years ago but they still taste the same
no matter how old they've been my father
has one from 1940.
that's just good man
this is good you tried jaffa cakes
before oh yeah yeah i like the zombie
cake
i just want to try for myself just to
remember we haven't had a twinkie
oh
i'm going to do java jeffy nice
job again aaron
yeah jeff okay
ready ready
i'm ready for this one
babe you got to do the cookie creams oh
yeah let's try it in the but normally in
the u.s we eat these warm there's
usually a sign that says
hot doughnuts now for krispy kreme and
they just melt
now what's this so this is a mini
victoria sponge which is a classic
english cake i'm gonna say that that
just looks like a fairground like you
know like a sort of village fate
fairy cake that maybe you know my
daughter oh
is that jam in the middle oh
oh you got all the jam
yeah thanks babe
that would go really nicely with a cup
of tea though
that was famously queen victoria's
favorite type of cake sorry queen
victoria krispy kreme wins for me
what would you pay for that fake like
50p
with inflation i'm not sure
you know what the krispy kreme is a good
like proper american classic i think
that you know that we've
you can't say i love a glazed donut i
love a glazed ring don't worry yeah
you're going to have steve
[Laughter]
it's krispy kreme right it's krispy
kreme
yes that's the winner oh yes
oh class and we got it
do it no
no
hold on wait okay so how do i how do we
do this um
do you do it proper tradition like this
don't do it don't do it oh god don't
just do it do it do it
like that
oh
god so much pride there's no cheese in
this like there's no cheese in this that
is the most that is the question
this is different we have the one that's
aerosol like you have the like the the
spray which sounds worse but like spray
cheese okay so this is real cheese so
that is real cheddar okay let's just say
that
oh that's delicious so in the us what do
you serve that with like what would you
put it on um
depression yeah i was gonna say
depression regret
oh that's a dollop right there
don't break
there's a there's a mineral necessarily
yeah i was gonna say what's the
ingredients for this thing because it's
like not it's not cheese
there's no cheese ingredient in there
yeah it's like soya oil bean this this
this wins uh this one's yeah um
okay
they're called twiglets
is it's kind of like you love it or you
hate it vibes because it's it's kind of
in the marmite family isn't it oh man i
don't want to do that then my mate is
have you tried marmite am i right with
that it's kind of marmite
i think they're both they've both got
like yeast flavoring or extra yeast
flavoring yeah what you said i did
what have you got here no no no no no
no man are kids eating these here yeah
i have no words i have no words that
that's it's just pretzels bro
oh wait it's hot buffalo
only in miracles the big smell of that
oh my god
only in america look at the color of
that thing you can paint a wall it's not
natural look at the color of it
ah
am i trying that damn that's good though
that's good yeah that's good
dude that's good that's like eating a
buffalo wing
oh are you serious
you know
what it is this is good oh glad it isn't
that bad
it really burns but yeah like
the uk one oh
have several uses you know what i'm
saying yeah this is also brought to you
by
cloche with more than one use
you can also vomit in there
what
oh yeah all dressed
this is exciting
i've been explaining these to margot
robbie
who loves snacks and doesn't doesn't
seem seems to be totally baffled by the
idea of an all an all-dressed chip but
it does exist
[Applause]